hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where i
i'm so pleased to announce that i
am moving for anyone who's been
following the channel for a while
you'll know that um
i currently live in a 400 square foot
studio apartment it's very small
i feel like i bring it up frequently
because people often ask things that
pertain to space like why don't you get
this and i'm like how i definitely have
to mention it whenever i do like an
unboxing or something because i'm like i
don't have space to do this the time
finally came
where i am upgrading i'm going to have
an office
and a bedroom
two
rooms
going from this space
to having an office and a bedroom oh my
god the context right now i'm sitting on
my bed
and if i flip the camera right now which
i will you'll see some of the packing
that is taking place a lot of my stuff
is already gone
sitting on my bed like i said
that's it
i feel like the camera's making it even
look bigger than it actually is
obviously that's my fridge
that's the kitchen
um my pc used to be where that that xbox
is right there
this is where my tv was it's my couch
that's the whole thing ladies and
gentlemen
this is where i have lived
for the last
three years
that and that over there i had another
tv right there as well
we're getting through it
we're getting through it
i actually don't mind having a cramped
space it's not so bad um but it did get
really bad during the pandemic um when i
moved to la and i found this place
it was cheap and i intended to save
money which i successfully did by living
in a small cheap apartment
but the pandemic
really hurt this building for me in
general for reference
if you didn't know
i
was in this one room entirely by myself
um for majority of last year
from lockdown in
march to december
literally weeks without leaving this
room i would get up off my bed right
here and i would walk to the pc
right right there
and i'd make breakfast just here and
it's all just in this room
which has no direct sunlight and no
balcony
um no breeze and
the light is probably what bothered me
the most um but it just
yeah if the pandemic didn't happen i
think i would have felt differently
about it but being someone who was high
risk i have asthma and i've had
pneumonia before
i've been hospitalized for the flu
before for context so
um
getting covered it's seeming like a very
bad flu i was pretty likely to get
pretty sick i have to be really careful
with this stuff so i was um you know at
high risk so i was treating it carefully
and that just meant
never leaving this apartment
for anything ever was just this room
it has everything that i
did need to function just not
necessarily what i needed to function
and also like
be
happy there was sort of an issue and of
course i'm speaking from like a massive
position of privilege here there are
people who are much worse off than than
i am just feels very cluttered mentally
when you work
and i probably work like 16 maybe 14
hours a day i would say on average
and then you just like go to sleep in
the same room and then you wake up and
you eat in the same room and yeah
it just
i think i sort of lost myself at some
point if that makes sense i just became
very robotic
also i cannot believe how dirty it is
now that i've moved some stuff
there is so much dust in here
also
my oculus rift um obviously i use the
oculus quest too but i wanted to keep my
rift
i
while trying to move stuff
put uh the controllers outside for maybe
a minute
got stolen
literally maybe 60 seconds outside just
my front door in this apartment building
stolen
i i wonder if they think that there's a
headset in there as well
like do they realize that they just got
controllers they probably can't use i
don't know sucks though but that's also
pretty indicative of the neighborhood
that i live in it's uh
it's not very safe at all it's pretty
pretty dodgy um
but
just wanted to save money
and i did so yeah uh getting to the
purpose of this video very late in this
video which is just like i'm just kind
of reflecting and wanted to talk about
moving but also wanted to say
um i don't know what my video output is
gonna be like as this is happening i've
already had to stop doing my resident
evil
let's plays um
because of that unfortunately i should
be able to get stuff set up again sort
of soon and internet and
all that good stuff but just not
immediately because moving is hard and
takes time and requires
unpacking and packing and i still have
to get rid of more stuff but the new
place i will have more space which in
theory means better videos
could potentially mean doing some of the
podcasts in person if um if one mike
bithell ever visits uh la i will try to
figure out a way to do play watch listen
in person that would be awesome but
extra nice thing for me is hopefully
next year australians can travel
properly again
and um we'll have a place for my family
to stay where naturally in this room i
didn't really it was difficult
to
have anybody come over at all i
virtually never had guests here like
almost never that the amount of people
had been in my apartment and friends was
like three like
i've played for three years i never had
people over there was no like come over
and watch a movie let's have dinner at
my place how do you do that when you
have [ __ ]
seats
so that will be nice too
yeah the only stuff left that i have to
pack all my statues are good
people ask me about that all the time is
like how do you move your stretches
you're worried about moving your statues
it's not actually that hard um because i
keep the boxes so
that was all right
i kept all the boxes in the uh coat
closet which is down the hall just here
excuse me that one right there that's
where you're supposed to put coats
because the bathroom is what's around
that corner but um
yeah i kept boxes for my statues in
there so everything was breakable
you just put it in there
and then the stuff that's not breakable
which is those three that are still on
the kitchen counter there um i wrap in
clothes and boxes so
yeah it's really not too bad
but yeah right now all that's left is
like i've got groceries obviously um so
i can still eat
i've got kitchen stuff a couple of um
toiletries but
it's really not much in the grand scheme
of things it's it's not much
it's weird
i will get too sentimental if you let me
because i'm a very sentimental person
but um generally it does feel strange it
feels weird to
to move out of here i've spent a lot of
time making a lot of stuff in this room
and um i don't know the problem is
really just i think after last year it
feels like a prison like it really it
feels like i just need to leave you know
again i feel tremendously privileged
that i'm even in a position where i can
complain about [ __ ] like that about
being like i just need
more space than my 400 square foot
apartment in los angeles you know it's
not that bad in the grand scheme of
things but uh
just something that i really wanted to
do for myself so
yeah
like i said generally this is just an
introspective vloggy
video um
and yeah kind of wanted to just issue a
like i don't know what upload's gonna be
like should be okay but it is the reason
that i stopped recording resident evil
um but when i am set up in my new spot
i will get back to resident evil 4 vr
which will be awesome hopefully it
doesn't take too long it should not
interrupt either of the podcasts or
anything like that um
[Music]
yeah i've been streaming a lot less
partly because of that as well i've been
my health's been a bit [ __ ] lately but
it's also because um of
the moving and all the packing i've been
doing it's been
overwhelming
i
need to get some more packing these
these two boxes that are left empty so
let's do it i also don't know what to do
with these games i was gonna sell them
like at a gamestop or whatever
but they're all australian
these are all pal video games so oh my
god i have to pack my wii u i haven't
had that out of a cabinet for ages
oh amazing that is it for me today
everybody hope you enjoyed this video
i'm very excited i'll show you guys the
new place when it's set up
super exciting stuff and i'll see you
guys next time bye